one of the other things you can do is
you can go back and watch what they did
when they lied in real time so here is a
panel of CNN this is yesterday finally
admitting that covid deaths and
hospitalizations were over counted now
the guests that they are going to have
on there's three hosts the guest is
Leanna Nguyen lyanna Wu Leanna Wu you
guys remember really she was one of the
biggest coveted fear mongers for
mandates locking people in their houses
and all of that stuff okay yet she's the
guest now as they talk about how covet
hospitalizations were overcounted the
woman should be fired and shamed and
never seen in public again
well just watch what we're going to do
to her here here first watch the the
part from yesterday
these are two separate thing
we're counting deaths and over counting
hospitalizations as you know I covered
this closely being in the Trump White
House when this happened I talked to a
lot of Health officials about this who
are actually kind of skeptical of this
claim that you're making and I think one
big thing has been what is the evidence
that these coveted deaths are actually
being over counted
well this is the reason why this kind of
transparent reporting is going to be so
important there is a way for us to look
at death certificates and also to look
at the medical records of individuals
prior to the death and I think this
needs to be separated into three
categories one is the um the covid as a
direct contributor the primary cause of
death the second is could it be a
secondary contributing cause so for
example somebody with kidney disease
covid then pushes them over the edge to
have kidney failure that's coveted as a
contributing cause and then the third is
covet as an incidental finding so
somebody coming in with a gunshot wound
or a heart attack and they happen to
test positive I think that we need to
separate out and look at the percentages
of each that percentage would have
shifted over time as well in the
beginning probably a lot more people
were dying with the primary cause of
covid that probably has shifted and I
think again we need to understand this
another reason to understand this too is
a lot of people are wondering when they
should get a booster next when do we
need a second booster or another booster
and the only way we can know for sure is
to understand who is getting severely
ill and when Connor just made a great
point that you know back in the day at
the height of kovid CNN used to have
their covid death ticker it's funny they
don't have their death Ticker on anymore
as it's becoming obvious that kovid was
largely a hoax and now people are dying
of vaccine-related injuries
[Music]
foreign
[Music]